elles ont fait le tour du monde ces
images ces images de la libération de
paris
c'était le 26 août 1944 dans l'après
midi il y avait des caméras partout
quand le général de gaulle a parcouru à
pied la célèbre avenue des champs
elysées et cette foule de parisiens
joyeux c'était un rêve pour ceux qui
filmait comme souvent dans les plus
grands moments de l'histoire de la
france une cérémonie religieuse avait
été prévue à la cathédrale de notre dame
de paris le général de gaulle y était
attendu par des milliers d'autres
parisiens et un détachement de
militaires français s'étaient postés sur
le parvis pour assurer la sécurité de
l'arc de triomphe jusqu'en bas de
l'avenue des champs elysées tout s'est
remarquablement passé
arrivée place de la concorde le général
est montée comme prévu dans une voiture
décapotable
il a rapidement parcouru la rue de
rivoli longue de plus de deux kilomètres
passés les bâtiments du louvre la
voiture a tourné à droite et de gaulle a
fait une halte à l'hôtel de ville puis
il est reparti il a traversé la seine
mais en arrivant devant la cathédrale en
quelques secondes
tout bascule
à peine descente il deux voitures une
fusillade éclate regardez malgré les
coups de feu de gaulle se dirige vers
l'entrée de la cathédrale comme si de
rien n'était
rien ne l'arrête la plupart des regards
convergent vers les hauteurs de la
cathédrale c'est de là que semble venir
le danger mais qui tire des snipers des
tireurs allemand isolé est-ce pour tuer
de gaulle ministère on n'a jamais su ce
qui s'était vraiment passé
pas d'arrestations beaucoup de
témoignages contradictoires et par
malchance les images filmées à ce moment
là sont rares ou maladroites comme cette
entrée de de gaulle dans la cathédrale
outre aux fugitifs comme celle ci même
en les passant très lentement elle
n'aide pas à comprendre ce qui s'est
passé
elles ne disent pas grand chose d'autre
que de la peur de la pagaille
mais coup de chance toute une bobine des
images filmées dans la rue qui conduit à
la cathédrale a récemment été retrouvé
dans un placard
aux etats unis plus de trois minutes de
film avec le son enregistré en même
temps ce qui était plutôt rare en 1944
le général de gaulle est déjà entrée
dans la cathédrale dont on aperçoit un
peu la façade là en arrière plan dans la
fumée des tirs pendant que dehors ça
tire dans tous les sens ils assistent
imperturbable à une messe
celui qui filme dans la rue d'arcole est
à une trentaine de mètres de l'entrée de
la cathédrale
il tourne maintenant sa caméra de
l'autre côté de la rue c'est par là que
de gaulle est arrivé en voiture
mais pourquoi fait il ça peut être pour
essayer de voir et comprendre ce qui se
passe de ce côté de la rue et là bas sur
la gauche vous avez remarqué
la caméra est tout seul sur le toit
d'une voiture le caméraman est peut-être
parti se cacher
pourquoi notre cameraman continue-t-il
de filmer dans ce sens de la rue c'est
un peu étrange
si de gaulle sort de la cathédrale il
n'a aucune chance de le voir il lui
tourne le 2 tous ces gens qui s'enfuit
devait être massés devant la cathédrale
quand de vol est arrivé la caméra ne
bouge plus du tout depuis